rescuers in New Orleans are still
searching for missing construction
worker in the rubble of a deadly
building collapse their dramatic video
captured part of the Hard Rock Hotel
toppling onto a busy street on Saturday
two people were killed 30 others were
hurt Matea virial is at the scene of the
famous French Quarter Mariah what are
the crews doing this morning
well good morning Gail we are actually
being kept about a block away from the
building because it is that unstable
here right now we know that the body of
at least one of the two inside can't
even be recovered yet because they were
afraid that other parts of the hotel
might collapse as the Sun rises here in
New Orleans crews are expected to use
the black crane that you see behind me
to try and stabilize the building this
morning two days after this
half-finished hotel came crashing down
the family of a man still missing is
camping out near the site waiting for
word any word including Anthony regret
his wife Nova I'm not leaving until he
comes out there appeared you can't
separate them two McGregor was one of
more than a hundred construction workers
at the Hard Rock Hotel his family says
the grandfather was supposed to be off
but was called in to work at the last
minute my brother's the type of person
he would try to get everybody out before
getting his self out he won't leave
nobody behind we need to move all this
back as possible I'm looking at some of
the structure is still unstable
terrified passengers on a New Orleans
trolley car were just yards away when
the structure came crashing down and
were caught up in the giant cloud of
dust which spanned several city blocks
David Downes witnessed the aftermath
with debris all over was smoke and
people running around just a authorities
closed a large area around the
construction site and evacuated nearby
buildings over concerns more of the
hotel could fall the cause of the
collapse is under investigation of
federal safety regulators are on scene
the contractor Citadel builders has been
working on the 18 story hotel since 2015
it was set to open this spring we can
say is that absolutely permitted up too
cold that sort of thing but the
investigation will go into swift mold
right after rescue hard rock says they
are not involved in this construction
site Citadel builders also says that
they are mourning over the loss of life
and the injuries here they have brought
in an expert from Europe to try and help
stabilise the building and says that
there are multiple investigations
underway right now Tony Maria thank you
very much